si la crise disparaît et j'espère que nous arriverons à
faites une grande évasion avec quelques motifs
non seulement nous sommes aussi des cuisiniers
montré ces noirs
les gens qui ont de l'argent et qui ont
le pouvoir a tout dans la vie qui n'a pas
Je voudrais tout avoir dans la vie
du soleil et du trafic de drogue avec du carton dans le
sous le nom pour sa part une réussite
comme cet espace contournait le pouvoir qui
Ils lui ont dit que la production est stable
l'allocation des marges
[Musique]
le maire beaucoup d'habileté du guerrier
Céline Dion l'a peint ne vit pas bien
ensuite être un peuple chrétien
l'atout avec détermination et concentration et
mercasa de pitis d'agriculture avec un
cuisinière logique ou sous un côté nous avons ceci
drogue mais manger ceci où cela
le champ n'est que de l'argent de ceux
chiffres à vivre
[Musique]
Jamais
que nous sommes arrivés
c'est le nom des salutations des gardiens
Je capture ici ce domaine sont quoi où
il y a leurs modèles d'où ils viennent
que nous travaillons à partir de leurs usines
allons-y en même temps
[Musique]
et
en action
[Musique]
il descend voir
les usages
la faveur a été déçue est annoncée
éloigné de l'option
[Musique]
le plat est omar
c'est un peu plus de travail que nous n'avons pas
que d'autres à travailler à partir d'ici parce que non
il y en a disons il n'y en a pas d'autres bien
seulement ça pour vivre
nous mangeons
pour aider les enfants qui grandissent et non
il y en a un autre nous savons que c'est celui-ci
crime, nous savons que ces drogues, mais
mais pour manger ça où trouve-t-on ça
de l'argent uniquement à partir de ces numéros pour
vivre
il y a des moments où les gens sont peu criminels
De ce côté des méchants il y en a un qui
vient un cadeau parce que c'est pourquoi nous sommes
ici en donnant nous les dépensons nous les envoyons sans
armé
[Musique]
d'ici
avant
DV
[Musique]
avec le texte
est un matériau
ils doivent lui dire calmement parce que oui
non non seconde et puis reste au fond
de ce fruit
C'est comme au plus une dizaine
grammes
[Musique]
et s'ils sont parents ou non, eh bien
ici ça ne peut pas arriver à la famille car
puis ici
tout le monde travaille souffrant pour
ils restent ne sont pas ce qui se passait
vol
c'est pourquoi quand tu travailles pour lui pour déposer
parfois malade mon fils tombe malade regarde
où vais-je trouver de l'argent pour elle
les hôpitaux hospitaliers ne facturent pas
de mes 2000
et c'est là que nous allons l'obtenir
nous devons travailler avec
Eh bien, je veux sortir mon fils
hâte d'avoir une vie pourquoi pas
Je te veux des amis comme je suis
souffrir avec ce soleil fait
la chaleur et je souffre de ne pas sortir
mes enfants en avant je veux obtenir
ami qui est enseignant un initié
mais comme il n'y a pas d'argent, alors non
ils peuvent sortir
[Musique]
ef
n
[Musique]
la plage
avec le nouveau paiement
lourdes-duran
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
Oui oui
la matière nous avons des formes avec des suites
du laboratoire où salle
ils ont commis un crime c'est 50% large 50%
90 000
ça ne va pas commencer à cuire on va
faire bouillir les élèves
Sauveur
le beau
ici nous versons un liquide qui
ça s'appelle de l'acétate
si c'est pour remuer le suivant sort
à bien plus
d'où le titre du nfc
le battre car pour qu'il ne colle pas
vers le bas pour commencer ce qui dissout le
opium se déposant dans le liquide
couple allaitant ceci est porté sur un bâton
tout parce que le plastique
pareil et plus
intello
présent ni avec l'opium ou est-il pur federico
centani avec ce qui peut tuer un
personne dort ce programme
ça a pris beaucoup de monde parce que c'est très fort
et des gens qui ne savent pas s'en servir sont morts
sélection de melon de différents mais pas
ils les connaissent pour avoir analysé
stratégies injustes et mythes découverts
présenter que plus tard dans ce modèle actuel
à partir du 31 mai
seulement nous pour la personne de plus de
30 000
avant de
du mineur
[Musique]
dernièrement
et dans les sciences dangereuses parce que nous
peuvent-ils voir les soldats ou quelque chose
faisons le mal nous volons tous
parce que nous avons une chance, nous courons
Si je ne peux pas, alors non, mais nous avons toujours
radio et quand ils s'en vont ou qu'on entend
d'où viennent-ils
Je m'appelle
maintenant nous sommes sur la route à masnou dans un
pc public de l'original
je n'aime pas
l'autre tout
[Musique]
mais nous ne l'étirons pas encore
nous devons nous rapprocher
reste avec une journée de prière
à présent
Oui
[Musique]
J'ai 23 ans et je commence les 16 ans de
cuisiner peut m'aider parce que
la nécessité est ce qui n'a pas brillé sur le
manque d'argent si nous nous entendons très bien
court à l'école et nous sommes arrivés à
travailler jusqu'à ce que vous arriviez au lycée et
du lycée je n'attends pas ou je ne vais pas
prendre plus eu à travailler un
que tu aurais aimé bien étudier
J'aime être architecte
mais on ne peut pas
Si nous partons d'ici, j'espère qu'il arrivera, nous le ferons
faire un grand est l'employeur du campus 12
[Musique]
et non
et ici
[Musique]
et s'il part
et ils n'ont jamais été condamnés ici à culiacán
avait un kilo déjà fini fini et
vend environ dix mille dollars
image de l'amérique sinon à los angeles
c'est une broche de 60 mille vaut environ 23
à 25 mille dollars et de new york vous
ils partent environ 35 38
[Musique]
aussi
jeu de hammerstein en cuisinant dans le drive
a quelques milliers de dollars de fonds mais non
nous ne sommes que des cuisiniers nous sommes aussi ceci
lire aujourd'hui est ce que la main parce que non
il y a toujours du travail de cuisine
et il pleut que les fam ont remarqué dans la région
et combien
pour la vérité après un certain temps
nous avons perdu le compte il y en a beaucoup qui
nous avons tué parfois ils nous envoient pour un
et
et ils nous envoient en chercher un et nous composons le 34
parce qu'ils sont accompagnés de surprise
portes tuant licenciement
ils ne l'ont pas envoyé faire la même chose qu'eux
certains toujours alicante dans ce métier
tu n'as pas à y penser avec le coeur
parce que
si l'on pense avec le coeur
Elles sont des femmes
et il doit faire si froid
efe griffin a ajouté la famille wilber et
ils supposeront une triste couleur dorée
ils se sentiront mal parce que pour la famille non
il veut que rien de mal ne lui arrive mais
pour un ni que la famille souffre
la faim ou quoi que ce soit à cause du travail des
famille
lumière ou si tu voulais mais tu ne peux plus
une fois entré ici ce ne serait plus
la seule santé les deux seuls amis qui
il y a ici en prison ou la mort
la cabane à doigts avec edward terry à gauche
ça vaut le coup parce que le salaire était bon mais
aujourd'hui beaucoup de risques
Mais si tu le vaux comme si tu n'avais pas d'argent
tout vaut qui n'aime pas l'argent
qui n'aime pas tout le pouvoir
nous aimerions avoir de l'argent pour pouvoir
pouvoir un peuple qui assiste à l'argent et
a le pouvoir a tout dans la vie qui
qui ne voudrait pas tout avoir dans la vie
argent ou plomb argent argent